Snoop Dog.
>> Snoop Dog. He took his kid to see a
movie. Do you know what movie? He ended
up saying some pretty bad remarks about
the movie and the production.
>> I didn't come in for this. They putting
it everywhere.
>> So, there's something in the news that
caught my attention. Um, Snoop Dog.
>> Snoop Dogg. He's not a he's not a u a
frequenter of the news lately, but this
kind of caught my attention and I
thought it was really interesting. He
took his kid to see a movie. Do you know
what movie?
>> Lightyear. Lightyear.
>> I never even heard of the movie, but is
it about Buzz Lightyear?
>> It's about Buzz Lightyear and and uh so
he ended up saying some pretty um um bad
remarks about the movie and the
production by uh the LGBT stuff that was
put in it.
>> Okay.
>> I thought it was kind of interesting.
So, I want to kind of discuss a little
bit of this. And this made me think
about years ago. We we kind of talked
about this um 10 plus years and probably
haven't brought up some of these
situations. So, I dug up an old
presentation
>> and uh I'm going to show you this
because I want you to see
>> how it's progressed.
>> This is way back when we said it would
go in this direction and where are we
today? Yep.
>> Um but this article right here with the
Entertainment Tonight says um Snoop
Dogg, he criticizes the LGBT and um
representation in the children's films
and he says they're putting it
everywhere. And I mean this was all
over. Variety is something from
Hollywood. And he said these are kids.
they we have to show that to this age.
>> I I agree with him. I mean, uh I was
just doing some research for a show. I'm
trying to work a show on a show about
Sabrina Carpenter giving that away
early, but uh I remembered the uh you
guys know who Bob Pitman is? So, he I
don't know if he still is, but he was is
the kind of like this big dog for MTV.
and uh he said something like um you
know we get their emotions going um we
we basically we've got them um so like
I'm I I got them hooked to my music and
you as parents back off and you know
it's the same thing that's happening
here in all these movies like Coco Coco
Melon Kendi who used to be a host in our
channel she she did a video on that went
pretty viral so it's it's literally
everywhere and I think it's very
purposeful
>> what I think is funny is the the people
who make a living off of TV and sliding
things in there. I don't know if you saw
the the uh performance they did during
the Super Bowl. I mean, there's all
kinds of sexual
>> Which one are you referring to? Cuz
there's many.
>> That's true. It was maybe a couple of
years ago when he did one with Dr. Dre
and all those guys. And I mean, they
were doing their old songs, but I mean,
it was very full of of sexual things.
And it's like
>> usually the Super Bowl has a lot of kids
watching it to begin with. So, I find it
interesting that he would even mention
something like this. Y
>> um but I want to show you a couple
things. Um you guys know who Edward
Bernay is. We've talked about him on our
channel before.
>> So this was a comment that Edward
>> Well, who who is he?
>> Okay. Edward Bernay is Sigman Freud's
nephew and during one of the world wars
in the very beginning. He actually used
the u propaganda machine that that he
had learned from his uncle and he taught
the American companies how to take their
their industries that were making all
this war stuff and turn it into um
machines that would make stuff for the
population. So he
>> like marketing, early marketing,
>> early marketing. And he really, the
country at this point was only buying
things that they needed. And he flipped
everybody into this, well, you need to
buy this thing before your other thing
wears out. That was kind of what he
wrote. But listen to what he says.
>> Keith, go ahead and read this.
>> The conscious and intelligent
manipulation of the organized habits and
opinions of the masses is an important
element in democratic society. Those who
manipulate this unseen mechanism of
society constitute an invisible
government which is the true ruling
power of our country. We are governed.
Our minds are molded. Our tastes formed.
Our ideas suggested largely by men we
have never heard of. This is a logical
result of the way in which our
democratic society is organized.
>> Um all right. This presentation here is
going to come with a little bit of a
warning. And the warning is for all you
young people that watch our channel.
Thank you for paying attention to our
channel, but you might want to go and
get your parents and have them watch
this show before you watch the show.
We're going to talk about some things
that are put out into a lot of kids
things, a lot of sexual things. And so,
we just want to give you that
forewarning. Please go ask your parents
if they say that it's okay to watch
this. Uh you guys can go ahead and
continue watching. But if you're too
young, please have your parents watch us
before we do.
>> Yep.
>> So, this is interesting that they have
since the early onset of our country
recognized that they can control the
direction of where people are going with
this thing called propaganda.
>> And if you just put it in things and
people don't recognize it, it can have a
profound effect on you.
>> Subliminal messages.
>> Subliminal messages. to illustrate that.
This is something that we used when we
would talk with lots of kids. So, what
you're seeing on the screen right now is
an image to illustrate what subliminal
advertising is all about. Now,
>> there is something sexual about this
picture. So, I'm going to give you just
a second to to look at this. And
clearly, it's talking about the birds
and the bees,
>> right? I mean, my first thing was like,
is it just a bunch of flowers? And then
I see a bee in the bottom. But what am I
supposed to do? You haven't seen this
picture. I'm not seeing this picture.
>> Okay, so this is this is
>> Am I not an adult? Am I supposed to see
something like sexual that I'm not
seeing?
>> You'll get it in a second. If you look
in between the birds and the bees, if
you draw a line from the bird to the
bee, then you would see that there is
the word sex that is written in the
flowers. Wow. And this was something
that um early when our ministry kind of
started, we we we' point these things
out that you know these were on various
products and you've heard the term sex
cells and there's a reason why Pepsi had
a whole line of of drinks that um had
the word sex written on the side. You
would not have seen that if the cans
would not have been stacked up.
>> So that's pretty intentional, pretty sly
if you put it like that. Um, but there
it is right there on the side of the
can. There's the word sex. Now, here's
another product right here that I
thought was a little bit more obvious.
>> Yeah, I've seen this before. I still use
this one.
>> Yeah, this is this is something that um
you know, maybe was in a foreign
country. I don't know if we have this is
obviously a picture of a porn.
>> What do you mean like they just didn't
know English or something? Or
>> there's there's one of an axe soap where
it's like a dragon at the top in the
shape of an S and then down below is Oh,
yeah. Okay. So, you have it. Yeah. So, I
just want to show a couple of these. Um,
there was a couple of bottles here. Now,
a lot of kids use Axe soap. If you've
seen their commercials, this is not a
huge stretch. Like, this is like very
much so in their marketing ploy, but the
one on the right is kind of an
interesting image. What does it say on
the top there? Um, Denique, the one
>> 33% more plus. I don't I don't
>> What do you get? 33% more of the girl.
These things are are subtly. And when
you see things like that, you're going
to link those two ideas together, right?
>> And the reason to show you this is they
will often use this tactic when they
sell a car. Why do they put a beautiful
girl in the advertisement of the car?
What does the girl have anything to do
with the function of the car? Zero.
>> Does it go drive further?
>> Does it drive faster? Does it go like
without mechanical problems? If you have
a girl in the car, it's because it's
pressing that chemical button inside
your brain.
>> I actually remember I I used to study
journalism many years ago, which is
actually was my introduction to media
and how I got involved with this kind of
stuff. But I remember I take taking a
class, I don't even remember what the
class was about, but they were talking
about this and they were talking about
the same concept of World War II. before
products were sold and and there were
advertisements but they were sold
looking at how practical they were how
they would enhance your life right like
>> if you buy this soap bar you will be
clean you know like a simple thing like
that whereas now it's all about emotion
and and I don't know if this was
something that little presented many
years ago or might have been in Scott
Ritzma's media on the brain but there
was a guy presenting uh talking to an
audience about you know how to sell
products emotionally and he said
Harley-Davidson
>> Harley-Davidson sells an emotion. It's
an experience. It's like, you know, like
driving on that motorcycle maybe with
with your lady behind you on the back
seat and you're feeling the wind through
your hair and all these different
things. Like it's an emotional
experience. It's not just I'm going to
ride a motorcycle to get to work faster.
That's right.
>> Nothing to do with that. And and what
people don't realize is the difference
between a commercial that is sold in any
other time of of the day or any prime
time or any night.
>> Why are Super Bowl commercials sold for
so much more?
>> I mean, everybody's watching, right?
>> Yes, you are. All eyeballs is one of the
reasons, but you are in a higher state
of emotion when you are invested in a
game that's like, you know, is my team
going to win or is my team going to
lose? That's different than most people
sit down and watch television just
normally. Y
emotional experience you're having the
better they can sell those products you
illustrate the idea that you sell to
people's emotions that's what you're
doing
>> right
>> so um I think this is very interesting
um you know even uh discussing like
movie and violence and sexuality and all
those in the ratings um you know they
started really kind of catching on that
if they made the ratings kind of higher
that more people would want to go and
and and watch those things. And you
know, there's a lot of articles that are
pretty interesting on this, but this
particular article was looking at the
the amount of violent or sexual scenes.
Now, the reason I'm showing you this is
because if you look at the date, it says
2014.
Okay? So,
>> when we when we kind of get to what what
are we exposed to today, I think it's
even much grander than this. But listen
to this. parents viewed they brief pairs
of movie scenes featuring either violent
or sex and after seeing the first movie
clip the parents thought that the
minimum age for a movie consent should
be almost 17 years old okay for violence
17 years and 2 for sex after watching
six the sixth and final scenes the
parents more were more willing to let
their teens see movies at 13 and and a
half or almost 14 years and 14 for sex.
>> Wait, that's only after watching six
scenes
>> because they were shown six scenes in
just those six scenes lowered their idea
of how old you should be to watch those
things.
>> So they're desensitized,
>> right?
>> Desensitized. Yeah. And you can imagine
like this this article was pretty
pretty, you know, eye opening like that.
And you can see today we are exposed to
an incredible amount of sexuality.
>> It's ratings creep. And that's part of
the reason why they change out those
individuals every so many years from the
MPAA is because uh they know that people
over time will become desensitized. The
problem is society as a whole is
becoming desensitized. Yep.
>> So you have readings creep on a societal
level on top of an individual level. Who
who did you say there was like some guy
who um raped and murdered a bunch of
women?
>> Charles Manson when he was in in prison,
you know, um he was interviewed by um
James
>> Dobson.
>> And the interview is very fascinating.
You can still find it on YouTube. Um he
really talked about what debased his
mind and it was watching pornography
that specifically had violence. And you
can imagine like like something at that
level. Um you're associating pleasure
with the pain of somebody. You're
causing them pain and you're getting
pleasure from it. And I'm sure that
that's that's you know just a quick fast
road to eroding your mind completely.
>> So the reason I bring it up is because I
was just doing some research again on
Sabrina Carpenter. A lot of her music
videos are very erotic, very sensual.
She's known to just be like doing all
kinds of sexual acts on stage, like
pretending, but it's really very visual.
Um, you know, performing half naked in
outfits that are basically to be safe
for the bedroom.
And then like, yeah, in a lot of her
music videos, it is extremely violent.
Like I I just watched one and and um,
you know, for for research sake, I had
to turn it off
>> cuz I was like, I I can't literally I
can't handle this. this is way too much.
Um, and it had a an advisory at the
front as well as like advisory, what's
going to happen in this? And I was like,
this is way worse than I was expecting
it to be. But again, it's like sexual
parading around half naked, you know,
um, combined with violence.
>> Yeah. I I can remember seeing um a clip
of Justin Timberlake when he was um
performing and I mean there would be
these 13 14 year old girls that would be
at his concert and they were like overly
I mean in-your-face sexual
>> and and it's like you know you're
exposing people to that and I know
Sabrina she got her start with Taylor
Swift right
>> no with Disney she's she
tour she she was opening for part of the
Aerys tour I believe it was Australia
actually but don't don't quote me on
That's what kind of blew her up.
>> That really got her the final, you know,
she was already on her way, but that was
the final harrah. I think
>> I know little kids go to those concerts.
You know what I mean?
>> Well, they do, but they shouldn't.
>> So, I think there's a good reason why we
need to be talking about this and why um
we're hoping that you guys as parents
are are are listening to this
information and and the purpose of this
show is really to show you where they
said they wanted this to go and where
are we actually right now. Is it playing
out like they said? Mhm.
>> Um there was a psychology science um
article that was written and once again
this is like back from 2010 11 12 and it
talks about the exposure to sexual
content in popular movies predicts
behavior in adolescence. So the more
that you actually have those things in
the media that they're watching will
directly influence when they become
sexually active as teenagers or adults.
>> So then they just put it in all these
movies as kids, kids movies, right?
>> Yes. So these are some pretty
fascinating articles. um key findings in
this particular article was saying that
the sexual content is increasing and
this was written in 2005 and they said
that it's up 56%
from 7 years prior
>> and 64%
grew in just 3 years. So
>> and this article is from when? 2012
>> this is 2013 but it's talking about
where the sexual content has really kind
of been driving. So, here's some of the
um the things you guys should do a
little bit of research, but um
>> why why are all of these things making
it into um these television shows and
how is that even happening? I remember
first hearing um of this guy named Ben
Shapiro. This was actually some of the
first videos I ever saw of him uh many
years ago. and he was a very he was in
his beginning of his um experience of of
starting to be public with what his
views were as well. He would call up
some of these producers and he'd have
conversations with them over the phone.
So that's what this is. This is a
conversation with one of the uh leaders
from CBS and Ben was just asking him
like how are these things getting into
uh these television shows and and where
is this mindset coming from? Listen to
what he says.
that that is one of the criticisms that
you hear a lot from cultural
right-wingers that uh you know Hollywood
is too left. There's too much sexual
content. There's one side of the agenda
being pushed on a lot of shows.
>> There's no question about that.
>> Yeah. So he is one of the guys that is
choosing for CBS some of the content and
he's agreeing with him saying yeah
there's no there's no question whether
these leftleaning people are is how this
stuff is getting in here. M
>> so he asks someone else, Fred Silverman.
Um he was also someone that worked in
the industry.
>> Right now there's only one perspective
and it's a very progressive perspective
and they don't even uh you know if you
want the other perspective it's well
it's not it's not available in in
comedy. Let's start there.
>> Okay. So he's admitting like look you
can't have another perspective. This is
the singular perspective that a lot of
these guys who work for these these
television shows, they're all coming
from the same mindset. And so it's easy
to get things into them.
>> Right. Here's another one. This is the
one of the creators of Friends.
>> Now, one of the criticisms that's been
made of of Friends from, I would say,
the cultural right-wing is that uh it it
always tends to take a consistently
liberal attack with regard to issues,
whether it's gay marriage or whether
it's
>> how could it not? I mean, you have a
bunch of liberals running the show. I
mean, truly, we we all come from a
certain place. Um, we're going to put
out there what we believe because these
characters mirror who we are. And, you
know, we've put together a staff of of
mostly liberal people.
>> You know, nothing makes God happier than
when two people, any two people, come
together in love. Friends, family, we're
gathered here today to join Carol and
Susan in holy matrimony. Oh my. Now I've
seen everything.
>> What the fact that they call it holy
matrimony like it's holy.
>> It's not.
>> At this time that friends was getting
some, you know, traction and was very
highly watched. some of these issues
were being talked about in the public of
should there be same-sex marriage
>> and look by putting it into the
television shows what's the result of
that
>> and you couch it in a little humor
>> you know so it's more palatable
>> and everybody liked friends I mean that
was a that was a you know
>> you know and this is the thing like I
grew up watching friends I did not grow
up in any Christian environment I grew
up in a secular country so yeah like
you're being fed at these ideas. I when
before I became a Christian, I used to
approve of gay marriage because
>> that's what society tells you. Yeah. And
you you don't want to disrespect
anybody, you know. So,
>> um that's what you go with.
>> But isn't that interesting that when Ben
Shapiro was asking him like they were
like there's not another perspective.
Like even Silverman said, "You can't
come from another perspective. You won't
get your stuff on there."
>> Right? And so now it's it's interesting
because we have like things like YouTube
and you know there's a lot more voices
than just what was available to us at
this point. But it's interesting to see
where this has is actually bringing it.
>> Here's one of the creators of a show
called Desperate Housewives.
>> Oh, I watched that show too. Terrible
show. Very vile. Very uh
>> lawless.
>> Yes, there was there was definitely
some. But but what's interesting is
listen to what the creators as they were
designing the show. why they put gay
people in the show. Listen to this.
>> One of the things I'm proudest about um
is the addition of the neighbors, the
gay neighbors on Wester Lane, because
they're there. They're a part of the
neighborhood. No one seems to notice it.
>> And I think that just having gay
neighbors be a part of the street and I
don't really talk about their sexuality
much. To me that became its own
political statement which is see you can
have gay neighbors and they can be
perfectly fine and fit in with with you
know the rest of the folks and it
doesn't change anything. And you know
you kind of hope that you're preparing
the way planting little seeds in the
minds of people who sometime over the
next few years are going to have gay
neighbors buy a a house on their street.
And for me that that's that's the most
effective political message is that it
it's not particularly aggressive. it's
just there and it's it's slowly changing
a perception.
>> So that's fascinating because
there's an article I came across from
it was
I don't remember where it was published
but it was eventually made into a book
and it was from a 1987 November article.
Okay, so this is back a few years ago.
what's calling the overhauling of
straight America which was later put
into a book and I think the guys that
wrote of it wrote it one of them used a
um a pin name because it has by Marshall
Kirk and Arasus pill but the opening
paragraph is really interesting says the
first order of business is
desensitization of the American public
concerning gays and gay rights to
desensitize the public is to help it
view homosexuality with indifference
instead of with keen emotion Ideally, we
would have straits register differences
in sexual preference the way they
register different tastes for ice cream
or sports games. She likes strawberry
and I like vanilla. He follows baseball
and I follow football. No big deal.
Well, he goes on and I I think the
second paragraph is worth reading just
to see how it correlates with this. At
least in the beginning, we are seeking
public desensitization and nothing more.
We do not need and cannot expect a full
appreciation or understanding of
homosexuality from the average American.
You can forget about trying to persuade
the masses that homosexuality is a good
thing. But if only you can get them to
think that it's just another thing with
a shrug of their shoulders, then your
battle for legal and social rights is
virtually won. And to get to shoulder
shrug stage, gays as a class must cease
to appear mysterious, alien, loathome,
and contrary. A largecale media campaign
will be required in order to change the
image of gays in America. And any
campaign to accomplish this turnaround
should do six things. They list the six
things, and I can't read all of them,
but I can read the kind of the things
that they mention. Talk about gays and
gayness as loudly and as often as
possible. That's number one. Number two,
portray gays as victims, not as
aggressive challengers.
>> This is 1987. Okay. Number three, give
protectors a just cause.
Number four, make gays look good. Number
five, make the victim misers look bad.
And number six, solicit funds. The buck
stops here. So this goes on in detail
for
10 pages.
>> Wow.
>> 10 typed pages of detail and later made
into a book of how
>> this is supposed to be done. And when
you read this all in detail, you can
look back and and say
>> they they totally accomplished
everything that they set out to do.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a playbook. Yeah,
>> they know that if they put that
constantly, like he said, in the
background where it's not necessarily
noticeable, but it's just it's just
there and it's you constantly see it
that over time it will change people's
public opinion. And it's not anything
that we shouldn't be surprised of. I
mean, this is one of like many issues. I
mean, we could single this out, but
there are many issues in society that
are going the direction of lawlessness.
But Jesus himself said in the last days
lawlessness will increase.
>> That's right.
>> So it shouldn't be a surprise.
>> We should expect it.
>> But that just means his second coming is
that much closer.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah. And it it's not We are now talking
about like the movie industry and all
that kind of stuff. It's not just in the
movie industry even. Um in the music
industry as well. Oh, I mean, Madonna
made this statements who knows how long
ago that she said, "If we keep putting
it in front of these people, maybe
they'll accept it and then maybe they'll
even get secretly aroused by it."
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, and she said this like back in
the heyday
>> and it's all being fulfilled.
>> It's very true. And we have, you know,
we have records of how, you know, mass
public can be a affected by a cultural
mindset. I mean, you can just look at
the the early world wars and you know,
Adolf Hitler, he made a statement that
said, "Make the lie big, make it simple,
keep it saying it, and eventually people
will believe it."
>> The repeat machine.
>> Yeah. The repeat machine. If you say it
enough times that then then people you
kind of like are rewriting the script in
their brain and it's like they'll just
>> That's adopt it.
>> That's why I get nervous whenever I see
something hitting the news.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't care what the issue is or what
side it's on.
>> If it's loud, it's big. and they just
keep saying it over and over and over
and over and over again. I'm like,
>> "Yeah, what are you doing?"
>> Makes you wonder. What are you doing?
Well, you know, we're talking about
homosexuality kind of like getting into
the mainstream and sexuality being like
more and more talked about. Um, this is
something that's been around for a long
time. And, uh, I can remember 10, 15
years ago when when I heard this that
the X-Men was really like this big
allegory for homosexuality. And I was
like, what? It was not. Come on. It's
the X-Men. Like these guys are like
these guys are like the the superhero
early this this series kind of caught
on, right?
>> Um here's something interesting about
it. This is speaking about the comic
books. So um listen to what? See, this
article was back in 2012. It says,
"Today we're pleased to announce the
mystery identity of one of the
characters in question is over and
appearing in Earth 2. Alan Scott is the
Green Lantern of Earth 2, a team leader
with a type A personality and an
appetite for justice. And Allan also
happens to be a homosexual. And while
he's or while his origins won't be shown
in full detail until issue three, we can
tease that the traumatic event will
serve as a catalyst for him assuming his
superhero identity as the Green Lantern.
M
>> so I mean this was this was you know
back in the comic books well before it
actually hit into the movies and
you know these things kind of change the
mindset over time.
>> I remember years ago I did a video kind
of exposing the Sims because I used to
be a huge gamer actually um you know not
just Sims but also like Grand Theft
Auto, Call of Duty, Need for Speed, all
those things. um Assassin's Creed and um
so I did a video on on the Sims and it's
interesting that even in that kind of
culture you see a progression where
let's say you create a family right and
you your family grows up your the kids
grow up and you say well I'm going to
take this one persona that grew up and
I'm going to continue living create a
family continue work we're playing with
this
>> uh Sim the other Sims just start being
like computerized that just live their
life in the background right so you're
not directly controlling them anymore
because she chose to play with this one.
So in later versions now your family
that you left behind could now choose if
they wanted to to become lesbians. And
it happened to my my my Sims. So at that
point I was kind of at my teenage years
I was starting to become a Christian.
And I remember that yeah I my my family
grew up. I was like oh this baby here
grew up to be adults. I'm going to move
on create a new family with this one.
And I was like, "Hey, what this person
that I created that I played with now
became a lesbian on their own." And and
then I started looking into trailers and
stuff. And I remember they had expansion
packs. And when you you pause the the
trailer for the expansion pack, these
images flashed by of college students,
lesbians, and gays kissing each other,
but it was so fast that you could hardly
pick up on it unless you paused or
slowed down the video.
>> And you wonder, your mind sees
everything. your mind is incredibly
fast. That's that's why like, you know,
subliminal advertising with the like the
sexual things written in there or the on
the Skittles or whatever, your mind's
picking that up.
>> I mean, they wouldn't do it. They
wouldn't go to such an extent to have
that part of the thing if it didn't
affect you. So,
>> Exactly.
>> So, the way that that that you had read
um a a piece that was talking about how
to change that cultural mindset. Um, one
of the ways that that that really
accelerated that in our country was
through the use in a movie called
Brokeback Mountain. Now,
>> it's not that they've ever had
homosexual characters before in movies,
but this was the first time that that
you
>> you saw them as the lit the core
American
>> cowboy. I mean, that was like hitting at
the heart of what America was like
standing for and you were you were like
really rewriting the narrative right
there. You know, this is fascinating
because remember what Madonna said that
maybe at some point they'll be secretly
aroused by it. I'm not going to mention
who this was, but I knew somebody that
they turn this on and I was there and
all of a sudden when they were having
this like gay sex scene, pause the
movie. Hey, you should probably, you
know, not be here right now. But they
watched it as a straight person.
Straight married person. Why? Why would
you do that? Why would you have an
interest in this unless we're programmed
to eventually accept it
or beyond? You know,
>> I'm always weirded out when I'm sitting
on an airplane and uh you see somebody
that's like sitting in close proximity
with you watching a movie with a
completely graphic sex scene and it's
like, oh my goodness, we're like in the
middle of the plane with lots of people
and everyone can see all the screens and
it's like how embarrassing. Like it's
just weird
>> and and I want the I was a child at the
time, you know, child not in a Christian
environment. So
>> what you described happened on a flight.
I think it was this year, but it like
hijacked all the screens and it was a
scene like that and they couldn't turn
it.
>> You couldn't change it or anything as a
parent. So they had to like shut the
system down.
>> Um yeah,
>> because one person was watching it.
>> Yeah. Well, I don't I don't know how it
came up. like the whole thing kind of
got hijacked. I don't know that somebody
selected it. I think it was just like a
glitch or something. But it's like what
an unfortunate glitch, right?
>> Wow.
>> But, you know, coming at this angle
you're talking about, you know, they're
coming from the the American, you know,
heart of American, you know, changing
what this looks like. It's not just some
guy who lives in the city or two guys
that live in the city. They approach it
from multiple angles. It's like that
article I read, it's so eerie that Bill
Nye
many years later talked about that and
he actually used those phrases. He
talked about it being like ice cream and
I think he even mentioned strawberry as
a flavor.
>> Y
>> So, you know, we we we actually made a
video on this
and we never released it. We didn't
release it. And we didn't release it
because, you know, contrary to maybe
what some of our our opposers of our
material uh think was we we we love
people. We don't want to
>> to just slam them and or whatever. And
so, um that was one that we really felt
like, okay, it's it's just maybe not the
right time. But anyway, so back to the
Brokeback Mountain. Um, there's a little
clip showing how the intent of this film
was really to change the cultural
mindset on homosexuality.
>> You got your wife and baby.
>> Brokeback Mountain looks like a big bold
manly western movie. But instead of the
usual boy meets girl romance, this
film's about cowboy meets cowboy. It's
one of the most forward attempts yet by
Hollywood to mainstream homosexuality.
David Capellian, author of The Marketing
of Evil. It is very very propagandistic
because the entire purpose of the movie
is to make homosexuality seem like
something good and appealing and to make
people who are opposed to homosexuality
seem to be bigots and homophobes.
>> There have been homosexual movies for
years, but usually marketed to gay and
artouse audiences, but not with
Brokeback.
>> They are marketing red state, you know,
bush country America. The way the studio
did that was by first opening it up in
just five blue state cities where there
were large built-in gay audiences. So
the first showings had blockbuster
numbers
>> and they got these high numbers and all
the buzz going and then pretty soon it's
sort of like the Emperor's New Clothes
effect. We're all looking at that even
you know middle Christian America saying
everybody else says this movie is so
great I need to go see it to see why
it's so great.
>> Is there an actual agenda at work here?
Alan Sears and his co-author Craig
Austin in a book called The Homosexual
Agenda warn about a complex and well-th
thoughtout strategy to make America gay
friendly and hostile to those who
resist. These Christian authors quote
extensively from After the Ball, a 1989
gay manifesto that laid out this agenda.
Many gays deny such an agenda exists.
>> There's no secret plan or even public
plan at this point. But the authors
themselves discuss in the book a 1988
summit of gay leaders in Warrington,
Virginia to agree on the agenda. These
authors are a reportedly brilliant
researcher into the brain, Marshall
Kirk, and a Harvard trained expert in
public persuasion tactics, Hunter
Madson. The two proposed using on
straight America tactics remarkably
similar to the brainwashing methods of
Mousy Tung's communist Chinese mixed
with Madison Avenue's most persuasive
selling techniques. The purpose of this
brainwashing, quote, using the very
processes that made America hate us to
turn their hatred into warm regard,
whether they like it or not. First, the
two proposed homosexuals and their
liberal allies should desensitize
heterosexuals by getting homosexuality
talked about as much as possible in the
straight world. Quote, "The main thing
is talk about gayness until the issue
becomes thoroughly tiresome." You can
forget about trying right up front to
persuade folks that homosexuality is a
good thing. But if you can get them to
think it is just another thing meriting
no more than a shrug of the shoulders,
then your battle for legal and social
rights is virtually won.
>> We're talking about a uh demand for a
behavior that not only wants to not be
condemned, but to have every affirmation
from every possible point that it is
correct, it's good, and it's approved.
>> Now, look at the media. There's a title
wave of gays and gay themes. The L- Word
is a Showtime hit that follows the lives
of a group of lesbians. Number one rated
Desperate Housewives even has time for
the occasional gay guy subplot.
>> You're gay.
>> I'm gay.
>> A flamboyant homosexual is one of the
main characters in the brand new series
Emily's Reasons Why Not. He
>> just doesn't seem gay.
>> I didn't seem gay before I came out.
>> Yeah, you did. Heights, one of the most
popular independent films of late, has a
closeted gay torturing himself over
whether to marry his fianceé or go off
with the man he really loves. Happy
Endings features another tortured young
man who can't be happy till he finally
faces his homosexuality. And here in the
latest movie section of the Washington
Post, The Family Stone, where a mom says
she'd just as soon have gay kids as
straight ones. The producers, which
features a wildly homosexual Broadway
director, and Capot about the famously
gay writer. Another point Kirk and
Matson push, portray gays as victims of
circumstance and oppression, not as
aggressive challengers. Gays must be
portrayed as victims in need of
protection so that straits will be
inclined by reflex to assume the role of
protector.
>> Suddenly those who choose homosexual
behavior, sodomy, are victims. It's
crazy.
>> But have homosexuals won on getting
themselves seen as a persecuted
minority? Turning to the movies,
>> the Bible is black and white. The wildly
popular saved portrays born again
Christians as cruel homophobes trying to
reprogram poor young misunderstood gays
in their midst. Trembling before God is
about how orthodox and acetic
homosexuals are persecuted and not
accepted. The conspiracy of silence
argues some gay priests areounded to
death because they can't act out their
homosexuality. And the list of gay-
centered gay sympathetic shows goes on
and on. Closeted Canadian homosexuals in
Touch of Pink. closeted Asian lesbians
in Saving Face. And the good, kind,
understanding homosexual next door has
been seen in so many movies and TV
series, he's become somewhat of a
cliche. These days, some 30 regular
homosexual characters are being beamed
into your home by the major networks
every week. As Kirk and Matson put it,
quote, "The average American watches
over 7 hours of TV daily. Those hours
open up a gateway into the private world
of straits through which a Trojan horse
might be passed." And speaking of
horses, like it or not, the gay cowboys
of Brokeback Mountain are playing to big
crowds in a theater near you right now.
Paul Strand, CBN News, Washington.
>> It's pretty subtle the way they opened
it in certain markets first to get the
numbers up. It's pretty smart.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, you can kind of see how like
today, uh, I remember when this was kind
of going around, you didn't hear much
about trans issues or anything like
that. And now it's like like this seems
super mild compared to what some of the
stuff that's that's thrown out there
right now. So,
>> you know,
>> I remember doing a show on uh Taylor
Swift and one of her music videos she
portrays in the exact same way like all
the gay people were having a party and
then all the Christians were portrayed
as like hillbillies
um who said had the signs up that says
um Adam and Eve, not Adam and Steve. and
they just had their tooth out, you know,
like they had a bunch of beer bottles
and like um Yeah. Just they just look
like
>> uneducated.
>> Uneducated. Yes.
>> This I think is why we see so much of
this today and it's people don't even
bat an eye.
>> I I think we need to hold up a standard
which is the Bible, right? And like God
holds me to the biblical standard as
much as anybody else. So, you know,
whatever temptations or sins I struggle
with, I can't just set that aside and go
point fingers at other people. I mean,
Jesus literally said that, you know,
you've got a board in your eyes and
don't try to judge someone else for
their spec in their eye.
>> But it it it it is about like like if if
we encounter a homosexual person as
Christians,
>> the right way to go about it is to show
Christ love to them because Christ loved
all these people. He ate with sinners,
right? But then point them to Jesus who
can give anybody a better life and set
them free from sin and and not say, "No,
it's totally fine. You just live like
that." So, are you going to go walk up
to a prostitute and say, "No, keep
living like that. You're totally, you
know, you're going to walk up to a a
spouse who's cheating on his wife. Keep
living like that." No, you you point
them to Jesus who wants to transform
people's lives.
>> Yeah. Crazy thing is you take the 30,000
foot perspective and the devil's just
trying to like look I'm going to get you
either way either I'm going to degrade
society's moral values or I'm going to
come in with a bunch of legal
restriction to combat combat that
>> you know and then so the flip side the
push back is well we got to restrict
people's rights because we need to get
back to these certain certain values and
the next thing you know minorities
rights are being revoked because they
see things a little differently.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. You know, X-Men was a movie that I
didn't even consider as having much to
do with it. Obviously, we saw from the
from the um comic book earlier that they
were kind of putting these in the comic
book stories, but um I remember watching
this when it was when it came out and
this thought did not even cross my mind,
but I think you'll find this very
interesting. Brian Singer's the guy here
in the middle and uh
>> Ian Mlen. Ian also who would play the
Magneto. He is a open professing um
>> he's openly homosexual.
>> Yeah. So Brian Singer's in the middle
here. Ian is the guy that played
Magneto. He's an open homosexual and and
he was chosen to play that character for
a specific reason. Um in fact uh there's
been some articles that have come out.
This is a snapshot of the article and it
said that I think um Ian Mckllen
remembers um when he the first time that
the director Brian Singer pitched this
role of Magneto to him to play the lead
villain and he says I think that he
expected that I was going to consider it
a not posh enough job and uh he
basically says to singer that uh where
perfect standins for this the X-Men were
perfect standins for the current
struggles in the LGBT people. And I
thought he was right. So, this is Ian
being interviewed about his role.
>> I didn't realize that Brian Singer was
gay.
>> This clip that you're going to see right
here is of Ian and he's descri he does
something really interesting when he
stays in hotels. You know that little
Bible that's in the drawer there?
>> Y
>> listen to what he does in those Bibles.
I was coming over here in a taxi and the
cab driver said to me, "So Ian Mckllen,
he's the one that when he stays in
hotels rips the part of the Bible out
that criticizes homosexuality."
>> Yes, it is true. It's Leviticus 18:22
that I objected. Or is it 22:18? I've
always got to look it up. Uh
thou shalt not lie with a man as with a
woman. It is an abomination. and and
they um I think the punishment for being
abominable was to be stoned to death. I
don't think these are very comfortable
words to have the bedside of of someone
who passing a lonely night away from
loved ones and uh I think it's rather
obscene and pornographic and and and
shouldn't be there so I remove it.
>> How many Bibles have you
>> I have no idea but other people do it as
well. People send me evidence that
they've been uh removing that. Wow.
>> So, that's pretty
>> uh bold, I guess you could say.
>> Very bold.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> Um, as you can as you can tell, you
know, if everybody had that kind of,
>> you know, attitude towards the Bible, I
don't like this part. I don't like that
part. I mean, you'd probably whittle the
Bible down to nothing. And so, you know,
the Bible needs to be read within the
context that it was written. Obviously,
that that plays into a lot of things.
But um this just kind of shows you a
little bit about where his mindset is at
in some of these Christian ideas.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> But listen to Brian Singer and uh these
two guys, Dan and Michael, they're the
writers of this uh particular X-Men. And
um listen to what they said when when
talking about it.
It's become more of a metaphor for
sexual identity and orientation because
it's more appropriate to look at a
person and to say, "Are you a mutant?"
You can't always look at a person and
know that they're a mutant just like
you. So, you can't look at a person and
know that they are gay. So, these two
guys that wrote this particular episode
of the um X-Men, this is what they're
actually discussing in in this film
Freak Central.
>> So, basically, when they say, "Are you a
mutant?" It's like almost like a
symbolic reference to are you gay?
>> Yes. They totally meant it as a
metaphor.
>> This is one of the producers here. Look
what he wrote. His name is Zack Stinz.
He says, "I helped write the movie and
can tell you the gay rights allegory
stuff was all put in there on purpose."
>> So, these guys are publicly stating that
they've put that in there.
>> Kind of like Wicked with Ariad Grande
and Cynthia Arivo. We've got some videos
on about that on our channel.
>> Very purposeful these things make it
into some of these things. Now, Brian
Singer, he was the the director on
Superman. And you know there's a lot of
Christian imagery in the Superman. And
so um he talks about you know his
allegory of Superman being like the
story of Moses or being like a Christ
type and stuff like that. This was
written in the Hollywood Reporter. Um
but it's very interesting. He says that
uh he really enjoyed that it had these
kind of Christlike things because um he
talks about it like I really enjoyed
that because I thought that the myth of
Christ is a compelling and moving story.
M
>> now if you think the story of Jesus is a
myth, you're probably not going to
promote it in any sort of good way,
right?
>> And then he's promoting homosexuality.
>> This is true. And so this is the scene
that he was talking about putting in
there that um is an allegory.
>> This will limit you.
>> There's some subject matter in X-Men
that's quite uh controversial perhaps.
It talks a lot about tolerance, talks
about faith, it talks about all these
different things. And Superman talks
about religion a lot. I mean quite on
the nose, frankly. And and yet they
exist in movies that aren't seen by the
select few or the critic elite. They're
seen by tens of millions of people
because they are those kinds of movies.
For goodness sake, there's a coming out
scene in X-Men 2. That movie's probably
in its scope is made on with the video
and all at over, you know, close to a
billion dollars and and seen by millions
and millions and millions of people. And
it's got a coming out scene in it.
So, uh, when did you first know you were
a
>> a mutant?
>> But you cut that out.
>> You have to understand, we thought Bobby
was going to a school for the gifted.
>> Bobby is the gifted.
>> We know that. We just didn't realize it.
>> We still love you, Bobby. It's just this
mutant problem is a little
>> What mutant problem?
>> Complicated.
>> When you have a guy like Brian, you can
pretty well count on the fact that he's
going to put something in it. He might
be doing a franchise piece, but you can
be sure that whatever he's doing, if
it's a franchise, is going to have
something of his own personal motivation
in it.
>> There you go.
>> I mean, there you go. That's pretty much
out of the horse's mouth right there.
And again, Brian Singer is gay.
>> Brian Singer has um gotten in trouble
over the years from his interaction with
young boys.
>> Um there's a lot of articles that that
you guys can dig on this if you want to.
In fact, here's one of the boys that he
sodomized and there was some
>> pretty crazy uh court cases around this
particular instance. And um I mean this
was put out on TMZ and he's describing
these awful things that that were done
to him in promising him that he would
have movie parts and all this. So this
this this we know of goes on in in
Hollywood, right?
>> Um did you guys ever see the the thing
that Corey Feldman did when he was kind
of like being public about like his
interactions with pedophiles?
>> I don't think I may maybe saw bits and
pieces of it, but I don't think I saw
the whole thing. Yeah. He's one of the
kids that came out, right, that was like
a child actor and it was like, "Hey,
yeah, this was
>> and he said a bunch of stuff."
>> Yeah.
>> He said a bunch of stuff.
>> Like he was abused or knew people were
abused.
>> What really harmed his testimony of what
went on there in Hollywood was the fact
that he was asking people for money. And
so they quickly threw that in his face
that what he was saying was not true.
And
>> but there's a lot of strong evidence
that that there's a lot of pedophile
activity in Hollywood. and you know the
little amount that we've been exposed to
hearing about it I'm sure it happens
much much much more and so sometimes
like um what Robert Redford said so you
know Brian Singer is putting what his
own personal life
>> experiences are and he's putting those
in the movies and that's how those
things are getting trickled down to
people and becoming these normal things
>> um so I I thought as well here's another
really interesting thing that was um put
in a rolling in Stone magazine and they
were talking about the Pirates of the
Caribbean. You guys see that?
>> Most of them
>> back in the beginning, the one that
Johnny Depp did way long ago. Listen to
what they said in here in a July 2006
or article written in Rolling Stone. Uh
Denique, go ahead and read this.
>> Well, there was a great book I read,
Sodomy and the Pirate Tradition. A very
interesting book. I wasn't exactly going
for that with the character and Keith is
not flamboyant in his actions. Keith is
pretty stealth, but with Jack, it was
more that I like the idea of being
ambiguous, of taking his character and
making everything a little bit
questionable because women were thought
to be bad luck on ships and these
pirates would go out for years at a
time. So, you know, there is the
possibility that one thing might lead to
another. You're lonely. You have an
extra ration of rum. Cabin boy. Oh,
what?
>> Yeah, that's disgusting,
>> dude. It's it's something that um
>> but the same idea is propagated by Grant
Morrison when he talks about um Earth
One and Wonder Woman. He's like, so the
question comes up because she lives on
an island that's inhabited by women. And
they ask him like, well, were they
sexually active? And he's like, well,
yeah. And they're like, "Well, there's
no guys around." And he's like, "So, you
know, basically it's like, yeah, I mean,
it's what it was."
>> And and you know, it's interesting like
like the guy that was one of the writers
for um Desperate Housewives, he said
he's planting seeds.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> And it's interesting to me that like,
you know, we are actually supposed to be
seed casters, right? We are to cast
biblical seeds. We're supposed to plant
little ideas and things in people's
minds and start conversations about God,
about the bigger picture, about
morality, about these things that we are
learning from the Bible.
>> And uh you know, the enemy does the same
thing,
>> right?
>> He's planting seeds for his kingdom.
>> Yep.
>> And so you can see that these things,
this was from a Hollywood reporter, have
taken a toll. many more people, things
like the Modern Family and Glee, you
know, that have had a lot of these. Um,
way back when it was only about 2% of
the population, and I think right now,
if you were to look up the statistic, I
think it's in the teens,
>> how many people identify as um, uh,
homosexual. So, that's kind of alarming.
We know that we have gone down this road
and this has become uh, stronger and
stronger in our society. And we know
that much of this has to do with with
putting things in the media. I
>> think that's what's shaping our minds.
>> And so we wanted to talk about this
because of obviously Snoop Dogg bringing
this up.
>> Yep.
>> And you know, he here is somebody that
>> I don't know Snoop's personal life, but
I'm just going to go out on a limb here
and guess that he probably doesn't care
too much about a lot of the morality
issues, right? It's it's it's
interesting because you think I mean I
don't know how he's leaning politically
but like smoking pot and all those kind
of things and drugs and it's a little
bit more of a leftleaning thing and then
to call out the this this LGBTQ topic in
kids. Now I I did see that he and I
don't know if this was like he he's
changed his mind about this but or um he
did put out prior saying I'm not against
the LGBTQ I just don't want it in kids
movies. That's kind of what he was
saying. And I think so too. I I would
say the exact same thing about even just
straight sex, right? Like you should not
be putting that in kids things. I like
nobody needs to know that at that early
of an age. And I think we have a lot of
problems in our world due to over
sexualizing children and kids and and
and not giving them the proper
perspective. So really we wanted to do
this show hopefully parents out there
take a look at at at where societyy's
going. Look, if you haven't studied this
out, um, our suggestion would be start
doing some research. Start getting on
your hands and knees and praying. If you
haven't had these conversations with
your children, have these conversations
before the media gets to them because
look at look at the type of content that
gets thrown in all this media.
>> And so, it gets really confusing to to
young children if if if the proper
perspective is not um shown to them from
the Bible. Well, if you're wanting to
raise your kids with a biblical
understanding of sexuality, um you're
definitely getting that from the media,
but it may not be in the same way. So,
Common Sense Media, um this is something
that they wrote about this back in 2020.
And listen to this. Keith, can you go
ahead and read this?
>> Kids are growing up surrounded by sexual
images and messages. They're exposed to
sexual imagery in advertisements, on TV,
in movies, in books, in video games, and
on the internet. Many of these images
are played for shock value, so they
often contain graphic or violent sex.
Even mild shows use sexual situations
for humor, and sexual humor is a
mainstay of adolescent entertainment.
The more prevalent sexual situations
are, the more normal they seem. Highly
sexual images inform kids view of sex
long before they've experienced it.
Nobody wants his or her kids to learn
about sex from the media. But of course,
talking about sex can be awkward. Still,
it's important to challenge the
exaggerated notions of sex they're
exposed to, as well as to share your own
values to help kids develop a normal,
healthy perspective about sex. M
>> and I think this is, you know, a a lot
of good advice. They're encouraging
their audience,
common sense media takes a look at media
and like tries to understand like, you
know, is this good for people or is this
bad for people? What how do you kind of
see some of these these things that are
maybe potential blind spots and and
encourage people to not just sit your
kid in front of the media and just just
let them watch whatever. These things
are thrown into increasingly younger and
younger and younger audiences. Spongebob
Squarepants had some terrible things in
it that
>> Oh yeah, we did a video on that too on
Nickelodeon Spongebob Squarepants.
>> Awful.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, you know, it isn't just uh
teenage things as well. But, you know,
the Bible has
>> some really great advice on what
sexuality is designed for and and what
the picture that the Bible gives you way
back in Genesis. What does it say here
in in Genesis 2:24? Den,
>> therefore, a man shall leave his father
and his mother and hold fast to his
wife, and they shall become one flesh.
>> So, you know, we we've heard this verse
probably a lot, right? But but look at
this. Hold fast.
>> What happens when you hold on to
something? It's meant to bond you
together. That that beautiful thing,
that gift that God gave us that should
be experienced in a marriage is done to
bond us together. And everything's
trying to break us apart.
>> Yep. And so if you want your marriage to
survive,
I believe that a really good way is to
give them the biblical picture of what
that looks like.
>> And that's a great way to start.
>> Keith, what does this say right here?
Matthew 194 and through 6. He answered,
"Have you not read that he who created
them from the beginning made them male
and female and said, "Therefore, a man
shall leave his father and his mother
and hold fast to his wife, and the two
shall become one flesh." So they are no
longer two, but one flesh. What
therefore God has joined together, let
not man separate.
>> Amen.
>> And that is, I think, a big challenge in
our world today. divorce is so high and
there's so many things stacked up
against your marriage that that that
will challenge your marriage. We want to
give that the best opportunity that we
can. And I think that we need to really
start talking to our children and and
giving them the biblical advice. Look,
God made this union to keep us together.
Amen. And if we do it in the way that
God has designed this marriage union to
be, I believe that God joins those
people together. Y
>> it's very difficult to break them apart.
And he's making a call right here. Don't
let man separate these things.
>> 1 Corinthians 7:2 says, "But because of
the temptations to sexual immorality,
each man should have his one wife and
each woman her one husband." Mhm.
>> So even in the New Testament, Paul here
is saying, "Look, there's a lot of
temptations that are going to come at
you. You need to be unified together and
you will have a better chance." So Paul
is saying right here,
there's a lot of temptations around. And
one way that we can begin to beat these
temptations if we come as a unit, a
three-fold unit, not just two, three.
>> Mhm. Make God the third string in your
marriage.
>> That's right.
>> And I believe that if you understand
what the biblical principle of marriage
is for,
>> the devil has a hard time breaking that
apart.
>> Yep.
>> I agree.
>> If you like this video, like, subscribe,
>> and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos.
>> And drop a comments below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
>> What?
>> Say that again. How?
>> No, I don't know what to say.
[Music]